we begin with this an experimental drug
and showing promise against the
coronavirus preliminary results from a
clinical trial from the National
Institutes of Health found that patients
taking regimes of our regime severe
rather sorry regime severe recovered an
average of four days sooner than those
who were taking a placebo dr. Anthony
foul she called the results a very
important proof of concept that a drug
can block this virus but the findings
still need to be peer reviewed so the
data can be studied more extensively the
FDA may now consider an emergency
approval to broaden the drugs used first
on CBS this morning senior medical
correspondent dr. Tara Narula spoke to a
patient in that study and a scientist
fighting to get more answers it was a
very quick onset it got real for me when
I when I laid down Sunday night couldn't
breathe
drew MacDonald's battle against kovat 19
had just landed him in the hospital when
he was offered some hope doctors asked
the twenty nine-year-old to join a
clinical trial of the antiviral drug REM
des avear I was already hooked up
getting my my medication for my double
pneumonia so I thought what you know why
not absolutely and how did your course
change over the next several days to
week after you receive the infusion by
the time I left the hospital I was
already improving drastically MacDonald
was one of more than 1,000 hospitalized
kovat 19 patients in the nationwide
trial those receiving REM desappear
recovered 31% faster and were slightly
less likely to die than those getting a
placebo REM desapear which was
originally developed to treat Ebola
targets one of the enzymes that helps
coronavirus multiply this maybe just a
first step
dr. jean murat so supervised the trial
at the University of Alabama Birmingham
the effort that went into developing not
just therapy but also vaccines for SARS
and Ebola has put us light years ahead
of where we would be otherwise while
drew MacDonald may never know whether he
received REM desapear or placebo for him
the benefit was always clear why was it
important for you to be part of this
research because I want to help other
people it's important to note that this
is not a cure-all but it is a step in
the right direction and it offers hope
that we might be able to develop a
therapeutic before a vaccine is produced
doctor pouchy says there's an ethical
obligation to immediately let the
placebo group know so they can have
access to the drug so he may find out
Tara after all you know I'm curious you
mentioned those therapies based on this
preliminary data does it seem like
there's going to be a single solitary
best drug when it comes to treating Coby
19 well Toni the experts we spoke to
said it's unlikely that it's going to be
one drug but more likely a cocktail or a
mix of drugs that target different
problems or different parts of the
disease pathways so for example around a
severe or antivirals work better we know
earlier in the disease process when the
virus is replicating anti-inflammatories
may work better later when there's so
much of the inflammation that's causing
problems now it's important to note room
desapear is an IV drug it must be given
to hospitalized patients in the hospital
as an infusion usually over several days